Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Herb
from Long Island. Herb, welcome.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. And thank you for
taking my call. Also for Herb with a harder age.
Speaker 1: Oh, you say Herb. All right,
fair enough. Yeah.
Speaker 2: And with a harder age, that's all.
Anyway, I do have a quick question for you, and
it's also about Trump. I know you've said before,
when Republicans accuse people of things,
it's actually an admission of guilt. Right.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen,
it's sometimes is it's not
literally that way. I'm not saying deny them due.
Speaker 2: Process one for one. But yes, it we
did pay attention to that exact. We
should take pause and think about it.
Speaker 1: Correct.
Speaker 2: So a lot of these Republicans are
saying they're worried that this is so stupid that
Democrats would assassinate Trump. Like, that's
absurd. We all agree that that just isn't going
to happen. However, what do you do? Likeliness of
an attempt, a not a successful one. Mind you,
I'm pretty confident the Secret Service would
stop it. Yeah, but an attempt on his life from a
conservative because of the Mar a Lago grades and
these ideas that he might have dirt on them.
Sort of like an Epstein scenario, whether he
did or did not get assassinated, I won't get into
that. But if that is the case, like do you think
that is something that could happen to Trump?
Speaker 1: So Will in the next segment. In the
email segment today to people write in with a
very similar idea to what you're saying right
now. I actually think that from a motive
standpoint, it kind of does pass the sniff test,
the idea being, okay, let's talk about the left
or deep state or whatever planning to kill Trump.
But really, we're the ones who want to
kill him to get him out of the way so
we can take back the Republican Party. Totally
plausible. I mean, really, totally plausible.
I just don't think they're that organized, quite
frankly. So I don't I don't actually expect
anybody from the right to try to kill Trump.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah. No, I don't think it
would be an organized thing. I think
it would just be like one billionaire
trying to do it or something like that.
Speaker 1: I mean, if we're talking about
something completely unorganized and random,
of course, that could happen there any there
could always be some assassination attempt.
Sure. But I mean, it's not really the type
of thing we can predict in any serious way.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And I don't think it would
ever happen. Can I ask you one quick nonpolitical
question? I would be on the air. So I know you
live in the New York general region. I won't
get into specifics. But when it comes to
food outside of New York, what do you think is
like the one food that once you leave New York,
you can't get it anywhere else.
Speaker 1: Once you leave New York,
you can't you get it anywhere else.
Speaker 2: You won't be able to find
as good a food. To give you an example,
I think of everyone talks about pizza,
but I really think it's bagels.
You can't get a good bagel outside
of New York, in my opinion. I don't want to.
Speaker 1: Know about that. I so first of all,
I was just in Montreal, Quebec, Canada. It's not
the same thing. Montreal bagels are their own
thing, but I believe that they are just as good
as New York bagels. It's just a different style.
And to be perfectly frank, I mean, there's a lot
of places where you can't get good bagels. Like
once I was in Indiana and I tried getting a bagel
and it was like, it should have been illegal what
I was handed. But but like, you know, in L.A.,
there's plenty of good bagels. I don't know.
But I do agree with you that, like, other than a
few places, New York is the bagel place for sure.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm in Ohio right now.
I live in New York. That's why I have
the Long Island tag. But I'm visiting some
family in Ohio and we had to bring them
bagels because they just don't have them here yet.
Speaker 1: You know, a crazy story. When I went in
in college, my girlfriend did a study abroad
in Spain. And this was, you know, years ago.
And there were no bagels anywhere in Madrid except
one place started getting bagels. And so she goes,
she's like, wow, this is great. You know,
I'm from the northeast of the U.S. I'll be
able to get a bagel. She goes and asks for a
bagel. Can I have cream cheese on it? Oh, no,
no. Cream cheese. What? What's that? We can we
can put mayo on it. So what they they thought
that the application for a bagel was just
a smear of mayonnaise, if you can imagine.
Speaker 3: Oh.
Speaker 2: Oh, God, that sounds
awful. I don't like mayonnaise to begin with.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and just as a spread, I mean,
come on, on a sandwich is one thing, but.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, if it's an additive. Okay,
but as it's main course.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now we're on the same page, my friend.
Speaker 2: All right. Thank you for the call and
let you get to other people.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it.
Thank you very much. Very, very questions of
critical importance, I would say for sure.